I've talked to Lorenzo about this
Transformers one and you get to voice a
character in this big CGI ilm animated
Transformers movie what can you tease
about Elita
I believe that's a character yes I'm
playing Lolita
um what can I tease about it well I'm
working with Josh Cooley who is an
incredible writer director who I adore
and have worked creatively with in in
other weight capacity and
um it's you know I think the film does
it doesn't look like anything I've ever
seen before it looks so cool it's just
got such every it's the texture of it is
so is so awesome I think it's and it
because Josh wrote it has it just feels
very
I don't know it feels it's got a great
like dramatic feeling about it's funny
but it's got so much heart to it like
all of his stuff does
um I I don't know I just I think it's a
different way of approaching the
this you know uh IP I think it'll it'll
I think it stands on its own it's pretty
exciting